richtig denn sie nachrichten
unfallchirurgen in deutschland können
bald überstunden machen denn der
bundesrat hat heute den weg frei gemacht
für scooter elektro roller
das hat uns gerade noch gefehlt
allerdings nicht so wie sich das unser
verkehrsminister an die scheuer
gewünscht hat mit fahrerlaubnis auch auf
dem bürgersteig sondern ausschließlich
auf radwegen und auf straßen
friedemann weise freut sich trotzdem der
siebte unsinn mit friedemann brise
massenweise elektro roller das soll die
zukunft sein
ja so sieht's aus jeder vierte deutsche
will dich so eine scooter anschaffen
muss man sich mal vorstellen erwachsene
leute die sagen ich kaufe mir jetzt ein
tretroller oder wie ich kaufe mir ein so
genanntes letztem eine wichtige letzte
meile wege cool was muss ich beim kauf
beachten und dafür die letzte mal sein
soll es ein vater sein was möchte ich
mit dem roller eigentlich machen
naja waschen legen föhnen was man so
macht mit dem roller als sonst noch
fragen wo wohne ich da wie schwer dafür
sein damit ich meine wohnung tragen kann
kann ich mit ins büro nehmen
du redest schöner von einem dollar oder
von einem hund besitzen jetzt eigentlich
das tolle an so einem ding das teil kann
man zusammenklappen das passt also auch
in einen kleinwagen weint ja so retten
wir die umwelt ich kaufe mir eine rolle
und dann fahre ich dem auto durch die
gegend die es eigentlich im moment die
gesetzeslage moment benutzen sie in
motor betrieben des kraftfahrzeug im
straßenverkehr das noch keine zulassung
hat das wäre eine straftat voll gangster
auch noch illegal die dinger ich glaube
der einzige vorteil gegenüber dem bus
ist auf einem roller ist man wenigstens
alleine
man ist auf diesen dingen jedenfalls auf
gar keinen fall alleine sondern eher das
gesprächsthema der stadt
die sind zum angeben deshalb gibt es
doch einen von bmw hier der als einziger
ein fuß hebel zum gasgeben der gut für
sie
konstruktion eines fuß hebels war die
notwendigkeit handzeichen geben zu
können man weiß er wie wichtig
handzeichen im straßenverkehr sind
aber das ist jetzt eigentlich mit diesem
neuen gesetz meistens glauben die leute
jetzt kommt das gesetz durch und ich
kann roller fahren alles ist gut nein es
ist nicht gut das fahrzeug könnte man
wegschmeißen er stimmt leider
die rolle die bisher verkauft worden
entsprechen nicht den neuen vorgaben und
sind bald elektro schrott das doch
wahnsinn und das verkaufen wir uns
damals zukunftsweisende
umweltfreundliche technologie micro
mobilität wenn ich das schon höre
da geht es um strecken die man auch zu
fuß machen kann dadurch wird doch kein
einziges auto ersetzt aber okay man muss
ja neuen verkehrsmittel auch eine chance
geben bei der erfindung der eisenbahn
haben ja auch ärzte vor der hohen
geschwindigkeit gewarnt damals hieß es
bei einem tempo von über 30 km h
wenn die menschen verrückt und jetzt 180
jahre später weiß man sie hatten recht
taxi der südinsel
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünschen überall
lassen ihre techniken liegen
und hier last jetzt das xenix ein
beschissenes autobahn
[Musik]